my final clip was one I picked because a
there's a direct call out of Donald
Trump which hearkens back to the
beginning of our discussion and B
there's discussion of the national debt
which I've come to view as an
increasingly concerning topic and it was
at least brought up a few times
here where's Joe Biden he's completely
missing an action from leadership and
you know who else is missing an action
Donald Trump is missing an action he
should be on this stage tonight he owes
it to you to defend his record where
they added 7.8 trillion to the debt that
set the stage for the inflation that we
have we don't get any answers because
Joe Biden hides in his basement and
won't answer as to why he's raising the
debt the way he's done and Donald Trump
be hides behind the walls of his golf
clubs and won't show up here to answer
questions like all the rest of us are up
here to answer he put 7 trillion on the
debt he should be in this room to answer
answer those questions and I want to
look at that camera right now and tell
you Donald I know you're watching you
can't help yourself I know you're
watching okay and you're not here
tonight not because of polls and not
because of your indictments you're not
here tonight because you're afraid of
being on the stage and Defending Your
record you're ducking these things and
let me tell you what's going to happen
you keep doing that no one up here is
going to call you Donald Trump anymore
we're going to call you Donald Duck all
right he's so proud he's so s yeah let's
just let's just look at that for a
second the self-satisfaction it's the
charts that line is like so lame and
grown inducing and it has been in every
debate clip Roundup I have seen after
the debate it has achieved exactly what
he intended for it to a and I think you
know I think he knew that it was like a
total groaner and he also knew that like
it would be at the top of the hour in
the Montage on CNN every hour and and it
has been I give Chris Kristen credit for
uh pure entertainment value
uh he's 10 out of 10 on both of these
debates um the you know that that that
also uh brought this moment which you uh
pointed you were tweeting about this
morning Josh uh that a New York Times
fact check was prompted by chrisy
statement that Joe Biden hides in his
basement uh this is false any comments
on oh my
God God I just I hate factchecking I
mean like ca because the the Temptation
that the fact Checkers always succumb to
is they go beyond like factual claims
and they talk about you know well like
this was analysis and was it good
analysis or did this lack important
context and things that are ultimately
judgment calls and I think you know like
in in sort of fairness New York Times
they're not so much correcting the
literal statement they're not being like
he's not in his basement what they're
saying is Well like they're like they're
saying Joe Biden doesn't go out and do
stuff but he does go out and do stuff
and he traveled to all these countries
it's like no like when you say Joe Biden
is hiding in his basement you mean he's
not out in public as much much as he
should be and you mean that his that the
White House is trying to control his
public appearances in a way to minimize
spontaneity and minimize the number of
questions he's going to face um because
they're they're afraid of what'll
what'll happen if he goes off script um
and those are ultimately those are not
factual claims those are opinion an
opinion of how much the how many
interviews the President should give how
many events outside the White House he
should do there's no right or there's no
fact about that and so ultimately that
what this from The New York Times is
basically ultimately defending the idea
that Biden is out there enough um which
I think partly is a weird thing to do as
a media Outlet when you know one of the
key aspects of of Biden's strategy has
been that he does very few interviews
many fewer interviews than presidents
before him have t typically done but you
know it's it's not even so much about
whether the times's analysis on on that
is right or wrong it's that they
shouldn't be doing that analysis at all
it's a question for voters whether they
think that Joe Biden is out there as
much as he should be and that's you know
obviously what Chris Christie was
arguing about
there yeah I mean
the
factchecking industry or complex seems
to have taken a pretty big hit in
credibility over the past several years
do you think there's sort of a path back
for that whole framework well it's it's
not clear to me what the usefulness of
it is to begin with I mean I think it's
you know people have been driven nuts
over the last eight years by like people
thinking things that are wrong and you
know some some of that is you know like
cancel culture and trying to to restrict
opinions but some of it is literally
about things that are wrong that like
you know there's you know there's been a
lot of prominent conspiracy theorizing
and a lot of you know like nonsense
claims about you know Donald Trump
really won the election and that's sort
of thing things that are actually
Incorrect and it it drives a lot of
especially liberals crazy and it it
drives a lot of reporters crazy and
they're not entirely wrong about it but
just sort of like grabbing people by the
shoulders and being like I'm going to
give you the real facts now is is not a
strategy that's working in part because
the sort of people who are bothering to
read the New York Times live stream
about the debate are not even the
audience that they they really need to
reach if they're trying to disabuse
people of f false factual Notions so I
would if I had a fact check arm at my
news Outlet I would I would just shut it
down if you know the most of what
appears in fact checks is stuff that can
just appear in a news story format and
sometimes even when you have a fact
check that's really not about facts it's
you know it's an analysis about what the
context for this ought to have been you
could repackage that as an article and
often it would be an informative
interesting article and you just lose
the distracting frame where you're
claiming to be you know setting straight
some some fact thanks for watching our
conversation with Josh Barrow you can
watch the full conversation here or
another clip right here